here's everything you need to know about
why turkey matters
turkey is an important member of the
NATO alliance for one thing it's a big
country strategically placed between
Europe and Asia it's got historic ties
with Nations like Russia want exactly
friends with many NATO members
everyone's still playing a role to find
a balance between Ukraine and Russia but
at the moment it's real important is
that it's blocking Sweden signing up to
Nato is that going to change I'll have
to wait and see
turkey has a long-standing deal with the
European Union where migrants who might
otherwise flood into EU territory are
kept in camps in Turkey in return turkey
receives billions of Euros now if that
deal were to come to an end there are
plenty of EU Nations who think that they
would have to deal with another migrant
crisis
well turkey borders Syria so at the time
when Isis was on the rise a lot of
people were making the journey into Isis
territory across the Turkish border
raising questions about just how porous
that was and that put Turkey right in
the spotlight of international relations
it's also a country that has close ties
with Russia and also trying to form
close bonds with Europe it is
strategically crucial